did you eat your breakfast jam sandwich
yeah a sandwich yeah the jam sandwich
yeah
[Music]
yeah I always love mathematics as a kid
so when my earliest memories is is when
I think two years old and my grandma was
cleaning the windows at home and I was I
was insisting that that she put numbers
on the put the detergent on windows in
the form numbers so I always liked
numbers and patterns and and logic and
so things are very black-and-white where
there's one right answer and everything
else is wrong I didn't like so
subjective shades a great time question
so I would work on math workbooks for
fun you know if my parents wanted to
shut me up you just give me a workbook
and I would just you know do sums and so
forth so I always liked mathematics math
competitions doing that was very
different from doing research
mathematics the type of problems that
that you're given in a problem book and
so forth so very can of problems things
you can do in five minutes or ten
minutes and they don't prepare you
completely for a research problem where
where you know you have spent six months
you have to read the literature talk to
people or try something doesn't work
what if I try it again
and it's a there's a very different
experience doing research but I like it
a lot better actually than and and then
all the puzzles I used to do as a kid I
don't do these things pretty much
anymore
my mother was high school math teacher
when she was younger so she did help me
a little bit you know you know when I
was a kid you know just talking numbers
with me and then I had a lot of very
good mentors when I was like 10 or 11
there was a retired math professor in
Adelaide which I would go visit on the
weekends we'd have tea and cookies and
you know he will just discuss some some
recreational mass problem which was a
lot of fun
he who tell me stories about how he how
he used maths during World War two and
so forth in you know to to do ballistics
and so forth it was kind of fun to see
math sake being used for something
he had a PhD in maths from Princeton at
20 and was appointed professor of
mathematics at UCLA at 24 I enjoyed it I
mean when I was a kid I mostly enjoyed
doing maths and geeky things and so
forth and no being accelerated and going
to going to uni that early you know I
was I was around people who are older
than me but had similar backgrounds so
we were add so the same level
mathematically so you know these people
five years older maybe but you know
we're both struggling the same homework
assignments we both like to talk about
various methods and so forth so I felt
at home you know so I did miss out on on
maybe sort of the regular high school
experience you know sorry I didn't go to
too many you know high school social
events and so forth I did a lot of that
actually 1000 grad school in Princeton
you know so I then I hung around people
my own age and you know we yeah then I
partied and so forth in it so yeah I saw
her slightly and we organised childhood
but it worked out well for me and I have
to say Terrance how was competing there
and he only got one out of seven let's
actually cut cut Terrance to our some
slack the guy who's like coming close to
solving the twin prime conjecture it's
actually pretty awesome because he was
only 13 years old he holds the record as
the youngest person to ever of won a
gold medal it was this question six oh
yeah yeah that's a famous question yes
what what's your recollection of it now
and wife and you didn't get it right no
I did not get it right I well you know
you win some you lose some
oh boy I I have so so long ago now I
don't remember much about it I do
remember once the other people was over
I found out that some Romanian woman had
stole the quick with the question and I
remember you know searching out you know
because it was really bugging me that
that I didn't have a thoughts of the
question there was a special trick to
silver which at the time was not a
standard trick that was taught here it
yet he's a method of descent he had to
forget the exact question yet he had to
show that something could not be up with
a perfect square was always a perfect
square and sure they if it wasn't you
could find a smaller counter example and
a smaller one the smaller one I think
nowadays it's it's become part of the
standard training in it's over they own
all the trick now but
now you're competitive we we the sort of
boy that would get upset about it or was
it just a fascination I just want to
know there was I want to know the answer
or you like angry I think I was more
obsessive than competitive yeah I mean
it certainly has been a group myself for
not getting it but I wanted more to know
the answer than then to win I think
there's this famous image of you with
yes a great photograph people want to
know what you're discussing in that
picture what's what's going on there yes
I think he was giving me a mass problem
which I did I think I even know what it
is because he did send me a postcard
afterwards with what maybe the same
problem I have it somewhere yeah I think
it was it was some maths conference in
Adelaide yeah I was like 10 or something
I don't know why I was there maybe
someone was some math professor at at
you mr. Attlee they told me to come to
camp I understand your he was always
very good at speaking to two
mathematically gifted kids and I don't
remember much about our conversation
except I remember you really I really
felt like I was being treated like an
equal like he wasn't condescending or or
anything like you know this is a very
very pleasant conversation you know I
mean now additions has passed you know I
mean it does have some sort of argument
for me I mean it's a yeah I mean I I
certainly wish I'd paid more attention
to him actually you know I mean like I'd
heard of him you know as a child but you
know he says no there was someone there
yeah yeah to me he was a someone who'd
like talking about me and that was great
he did write me a letter recommendation
for 4th for Princeton later on so he did
hurt my career directly did you ever
have people you looked up to and thought
they were like the top guns not really I
mean you know I would learn about boiler
and Gauss and Newton it's awful but but
these were largely just names yeah I
think I didn't really have a sense of
you know so I had learned ways theorems
and tricks and so forth but I am I
didn't really have a good sense of what
was the most important or what was the
what was the yeah I didn't the why of
mathematics into a little later I
remember when I was learning calculus I
I thought that the most important method
ition would not be Taylor because
Taylor's name appears everywhere in
in undergraduate calculus Taylor
expansion Taylor's will and so forth and
you know he was a good math addition but
but yeah you know there are many other
people who did get good stuff this is
not taught as much in their daily
undergraduate level
[Music]
when you're doing mathematics do you use
any kind of visualization in your head
what does it look like in your head when
you're doing math that's a bit hard to
explain yeah it's always always a
combination of thinking inside your head
and speaking out loud and working on the
board you do try to isolate sort of the
simplest metaphor or something for your
problem like how can I explain it so you
know for instance um I do a lot of
estimates it says I always went with X
less than Y and sometimes it helps to to
think of this as of economics problems
like you have a budget of Y and can you
afford X and then and that that way you
you start thinking economically like
like yeah so the way you put in equality
is like a first and why is that you
normally you you maybe try to first buy
an X 5 X by Z and then Z by W and then W
by Y so forth and this is like no
trading in you know one item for another
item and you get a sense of sort of what
what inequalities are sort of good deals
for you that you're getting you're
getting your bang for your buck and
which ones are really wasting your money
come on utilizing through your financial
intuition can be helpful algebra in
topology those those out those have
always been my my weakest areas I've
only been able to get a handle on these
areas generally by translating them into
other types of mathematics geometry or
analysis yeah I have better better
handle on it I so they don't claim any
mastery of all of mathematics nothing
nobody can do that not sin not since
Hilbert the work I'm proudest of is
almost all joint work and yeah I think
most now adays most of most of my work
is joint it is really fun to talk over a
math problem at a really high level were
the co-author who who is really on your
wavelength understands what you're
thinking it's actually yeah it's saying
things out loud it's it's it's more
forces you to think like a more
organized level than anything in your
head working to be a bit John Borden and
vague and it's a small fun you know you
can go back and forth and if you're
stuck maybe your course has a suggestion
if he or she stuck you you make such a
suggestion you at least guaranteed one
other person is interested in what
you're doing you know when you write
something when you write a paper by
yourself you know there's always somehow
the nagging fear at the back of your
mind that maybe you know no one will
care about this
but you know at least the one person to
talk about it with what do you think or
feel of what's your impression of those
mathematicians that go the opposite way
Andrew Wiles is an obvious example the
mathematician who works in solitude how
does that impress you what do you do was
very impressive idea you need both you
need people who who focus very very hard
on one very narrow problem working for
years become a very deep expert but then
you need the people who can connect
things from fragmented fuels I make my
living you know about by understanding
one fuel ex and taking some ideas from
that and applying it to field why but I
couldn't do that if there weren't people
who are very deeply working in fuel
decks and so forth so I think it is
great that there's a there's a huge
diversity in mathematics you know if we
all thought the same way we all had a
similar philosophy would be a much
poorer environment you know you can't
really call your shots in mathematics
some problems I just sometimes that the
tools are not there it isn't it doesn't
matter how how smart a quick you are I
think the analogy I have is is like
climbing if you want to climb at a cliff
that 10 meters high you can probably do
it with you know the right tools and
equipment but you know if it's a sheer
cliff face you know Wow hi and this is
no hand holds whatsoever you know just
forget it it doesn't matter how strong
you are whatever you have to wait until
there's some sort of breakthrough like
some some opening occurs like halfway
through halfway up the cliff and now you
have some stuff some easier sub-goal you
know that there's some speculation
there's some possible ways to attack the
conjecture but nothing is really
promising currently you are not climbing
that clear but if a few footholds appear
you might run in try and climb it as
well yeah yeah yeah no it would yeah
this this is the way it works yes
whenever there's an exciting
breakthrough like everyone just sort of
in the new by in the ariados of takes a
look at it at their favorite list of
open problems they say ok maybe this new
trick can give you some advice it's very
hard to rule out that there's some major
breakthrough and so something which
seemed impossible it suddenly becomes
very very feasible this has happened
many times
[Music]
see that that is not the same thing as
the full kakeya problem
because maybe as the direction varies
smoothly
maybe the pole would have to jump around